und lass diesen ausflug ganzen noch die
krone aufgesetzt hat dann hab ich
gedacht okay mein hals habe ich an
halsschmerzen nimmst du doch hier noch
so einem softeis und ich sag ein softeis
bitten habe ich mich gefühlt wie bei
mcdonald's oder burger king früher
unsere zog da ist maschine ist leider
außer betrieb
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video
ja und ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
gut wie nicht ganz so ich bin ein
bisschen kann das video was jetzt habe
ich gestern aufgenommen also das was
jetzt gerade ich tun werde
das weiß ich jetzt noch sagen werde
nämlich danach auf also dass videos
eigentlich so weit schon fertig hat dann
diese wahrscheinlich schon gelesen es
geht heute um 24 stunden also 924
schönen challenge diesmal 24 schossen
habt ihr euch wünscht fand ich
eigentlich ganz interessant ich bin die
grad man auch auf die website gegangen
also ich hab das wie gesagt jetzt schon
hinter mir
es gibt allerdings die sehr viele sachen
dort habe ich bemerken frühstück über
bis torwart immer genau dieses ganz
typische hat hier panzer lottis wusste
ich auch nicht was das ist habe ich
vorher noch nie gehört habe ich aber mal
probiert also wirklich viel auch zum
frühstück also das wird jetzt irgendwie
gar nicht alles angezeigt aber ich war
sehr überrascht
es gab wirklich eine sehr sehr große
auswahl und ja das gibt es heute ich
will gar nicht lange lagern ihr könnt
sehr gerne weitere ideen für weitere
challenges in die kommentare schreiben
nächste woche gibt es glaube ich 24
stunden luxus essen da habe ich auch
drauf wenn ihr darauf griff hat gibt
noch nach oben wenn dieses format
weitergehen soll einfach doch nach oben
und jetzt viel spaß mit dem video sollte
auf geht's zur kehre ich merke ich mir
ein bisschen erkältet
[Musik]
leute die folgende aufnahme muss ich
nach synchronisieren der ton bei extrem
schlecht weil es plötzlich so windig war
ich hab das leben wie gar nicht so
wahrgenommen und ich habe mit mikrofon
vergessen als ich bin auf jeden fall
angekommen im hintergrund seet de gea
und ich würde sagen wir gehen wir
schnell rein
der plan für jetzt war dass ich mir erst
mal frühstück hole mal schauen was da so
gibt gefrühstückt habe ich dann noch nie
danach nehme ich mir natürlich auch noch
was für zu hause mit mittagessen und
bestenfalls abendessen
ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was es
dort alles so gibt natürlich kenne ich
einiges war ich schon einmal dort war
aber so ganz ins detail bin ich auch
noch nicht gegangen
deswegen wird es also irgendwie habe ich
mich jetzt leicht verlaufen
ich wollte doch nur ins restaurant diese
leute frühstück habe ich weiß nicht
warum ich kokain genommen habe aber an
sich gar nicht so schlecht kann
allerdings alles zusammen neun euro 15
gekostet die günstigsten
es sind
da muss ich doch mal gesund
[Musik]
so leute frühstücken jetzt geht es nach
unten
also ist also für leute jetzt müsste
hört schon wieder eine ehrenrunde drehen
hier also das haben sie ja schlau
gemacht dass wir uns immer an den ganzen
waren vorbei ist damit schon einen
kilometer gelaufen
[Musik]
ich habe mir jetzt ein paar sachen kauf
möglicherweise hat eine tüte für mich
normalerweise muss man dass wir da ist
man durch sagen es war irgendwie auch
echt anstrengend kann aber auch daran
liegen weil ich ein bisschen kommt werde
also kurz zusammengefasst ich habe mir
jetzt dieses frühstück holen das hat
neun euro 15 gekostet war okay ich mein
ich habe auch wirklich viel probiert das
auch so eine frucht hat dabei der hat
irgendwie 2005 kostet habe ich gesehen
dann muss ich dazu sagen ich kannte
dieses restaurant gar nicht so wirklich
also ich hab das glaube ich schon mal
gesehen aber so wirklich wahrgenommen
halt nicht und dann nur halt diesen
stand wo es dann dieser hot dogs gibt
und diese schwedischen speisen halt es
hat doch überhaupt schwedische halt das
womit man eigentlich er verbindet und da
habe ich jetzt auch noch zwei drei menüs
mitgenommen für später kann aber auch
sein dass ich auf jeden fall noch mal
hinfahren muss ich weiß nicht auf jeden
fall war ich relativ begeistert von
diesem restaurant da kommen sicherlich
auch sehr viele einfach nur hin um dazu
essen die halt gar nicht einkaufen
wollen weil es ist wirklich nicht teuer
der 242 das übrigens kein werbe video
hier bezahlt zwar für zwei essen mit
getränk den euro also vorerst 15 euro
mit getränken fand ich jetzt echt
günstig und das war gar nicht mal
schlecht aus gut wir fahren jetzt wieder
zurück und gefrühstückt habe ich schon
mal auch ziemlich gesund muss ich sagen
ist auf jeden fall alles cool muss mir
so ein bisschen ausruhen weil euch eins
muss ich nur sagen ich hab mir gerade
mal diese cola geholt einfach um die mal
zu probieren so macht es nicht es ist
echt nicht gut leute eine sache was ich
noch erzählen die ich echt lustig waren
so dass die kamera ist ein bisschen
als ich da durch die laufenden lief die
ganze zeit werbung und zwar in schweden
kriegen die kinder jede samstag
süßigkeit jetzt hier bei uns 100 gramm
flüssigkeit mit für nur 99 cent oder
dachte ich mir so baumann die armen
eltern wenn du da mit deinem kind hinke
ist und das kind das hört das nimmt das
java also du hast verloren ich finde es
dann immer schon ein bisschen fragwürdig
ob das so gut ist frei so werden alle
kinder ja dicker und naja gut so wieder
zurück hier mit meiner kirche ja
durchaus mit köpfchen tüten oder sofort
becken so leute wir haben jetzt mit tag
ich habe mir eben noch etwas mitgenommen
das ding ist das hot dog ich habe es im
kühlschrank getan damit es halt
möglichst gut erhalten bleibe ich eben
kennen hat und das heute und jetzt
andere dinge sind grad im backofen
probiere ich gleich rot weiß ich auch
wie es schmeckt ich muss sagen gekommen
ist habe ich dort noch nie probiert aber
was will man da groß falsch machen alle
geschmäcker auf jeden fall wie über
andere leute ich habe mich immer schon
gefragt was das für ein ding ist können
wir kalt oder seine also weiß ich nicht
ich habe ich nicht so darauf geachtet
wer kauft so laut ich habe das hier
jetzt mal ein bisschen aufgewärmt das
irgendwie steinhart ja ich jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt was da drin ist okay
eigentlich wie ich es mir gedacht hat
wir haben einfach besser und tomatensoße
glaub ich trotz das ist jetzt gar nicht
mal unbedingt frisches schmeckt es
wirklich gut immer mitdenken
ich habe extra nach austrian mitgenommen
leute gut wie in hot schmeckt muss ich
jetzt nicht mehr klären
deshalb ist antik erding schmeckt
wirklich gut das ding ist
mir fällt mir grad auch wir haben jetzt
erst mittags oder irgendwie so 14.30
das heißt ich muss auf jeden fall heute
abend nochmal losfahren mal davon bleibe
ich nicht sagt auch kleinsten also wir
sehen uns später
ich genieße jetzt erstmal hier mein
calzone artiges etwas und
bis gleich leute was geht
wir haben ein kleines problem und zwar
oder was als kleines problem 1000 es
jetzt schon dunkel
ich wollte mich eigentlich am sparen
jetzt hinsetzen mein foto bearbeiten was
jetzt jeden tag irgendwann abends auf
insgesamt kostet also wenn ihr mir da
nicht folgt macht das auf jeden fall
dass ich einfach alex wie weit ich war
mir wirklich sicher dass ikea bis 22 uhr
aufhalten
also ich muss mich jetzt wo es manchen
ich muss mich jetzt wirklich extreme ein
weil ich habe google hat nur bis 20 uhr
auf und wir haben jetzt von halle also
halb acht und damit ich die challenge
jetzt nicht wieder irgendwie pausieren
muss oder irgendwie so ein bisschen
morgen muss muss sich ja schon mal habe
ich mir gedacht du versuchst einfach
wenn ich pech hat stündlich und
vielleicht habe ich schon zu also das
restaurant ja keine ahnung arbeit sind
und ich hoffe ich noch was zu essen
sonst habe ich ein kleines problem bei
dieser challenge ist so ein wirklich
viel sein und nicht gefällt das ist mir
ganz wichtig also das wünscht mir glück
ich hoffe ich schaffe es so leute ich
hab's geschafft
ich habe hier noch zehn minuten also ich
will jetzt gar nicht lange mit der
kamera quatschen hier bin ich ich glaube
hier war ich heute morgen auch schon mal
wenn mich nicht alles sieht so ähnlich
aus also ich renne zum beispiel rein
schauen ob ich irgendwas findet was cool
ist was gesundes was ich noch nicht
gegessen habe und was vielleicht so ein
bisschen nach keine ahnung los geht's so
leute jetzt bin ich wieder zurück haben
doch gerade was bekommen und ich bin ein
bisschen enttäuscht und traurig das ding
ist nämlich mal kurz auf meine kamera
das ding ist nämlich ich habe jetzt
gerade noch einen crêpe stand gesehen
und ein smoothie stand die hatten
allerdings beide schon zu das musste ich
wieder zu diesem motto stand ich hätte
natürlich auch noch weiter ins
restaurant gehen können da war ich mir
allerdings und auf das dach offen hat
weil da hätte ich wieder ganz rumlaufen
müssen und irgendwie gibt's ja auch nur
so kartoffel zeug also ist jetzt auch
nichts besonderes
deswegen habe ich jetzt noch mal panzer
hottie nennt sich das das ist das einzig
gute jetzt das habe ich herausgefunden
und dazu sein himbeer getränk ich möchte
aber nicht gut und macht diesen ausflug
ich gerade noch die krone aufgesetzt hat
dann habe ich mein halt ein bisschen
halt schmeißt du nimmst du doch hier
noch so ein softeis und ich sagt ein
softeis bitte noch habe ich mich gefühlt
wie bei mcdonald's oder burger king
früher unsere tochter maschine ist
leider außer betrieb also das frische
über echt super war ich locker auch
gesund ja alles was danach hatten
nicht so zufrieden gestellt übrigens
wenn ihr mal sehen weil wir das von
denen aus sie zu ich muss jetzt erst mal
nach hause
fußball star gleich an dass gleich
arbeite ich muss sagen ich habe ihm ganz
wie schon gesagt dass mir echt nicht gut
ging und gestern abend habe ich dann
auch viel wald gekriegt und hat ja auch
gar keinen hunger mehr auf irgendwas ich
habe eigentlich noch so einen donut
mitgenommen also eigentlich habe ich mir
für die challenge gedacht dass ich es
versuche so gesund wie möglich zu machen
weil das sollte man ja eigentlich tun
man hat nicht ganz geklappt ich weiß
auch das frühstück war es jetzt nicht so
gesund trotzdem rechnen jetzt schnell
noch zusammen was ich alles gekauft habt
wie viel geld und vor allem wie viele
kalorien es war ein halbes vergleich
letzte woche beim kino essen hatte ich
glaube ich 3000 kalorien und 28 euro das
so wahnsinnig oder 25 euro
welche wir schnell die preise zusammen
neun euro 15 für das frühstück plus 5
euro für das mittagessen plus ja habe
ich nicht ganz vergessen aber eigentlich
auf fünf euro den e 350 eigentlich habe
ich für den ganzen tag 16 eur 65
gebraucht bist ja echt nicht viel also
oder was herzlich fiel aber letztes mal
was mehr ist ein mittelwert würde ich
sagen jetzt kommen wir zu den kalorien
wir hatten zum frühstück ein
käsebrötchen das hat hier laut der
website ungefähr 300 kalorien
dann hatte ich ja noch den pudding mit
dem bären schwierig herauszufinden ich
will jetzt einfach mal sagen das waren
sicherlich 180 kalorien
ja gut im wasser hatte ich noch 0 war
mir klar
ach ja nicht zu vergessen die ketten und
dann sind wir aber auch schon durch dann
sind wir insgesamt bei 1859 kalorien
ungefähr fluss - 150 würde ich mal sagen
also ich glaube dass du da ist damit
nicht nur bedeckt von mir naja war
wieder ganz cool ganz interessant
michael bock auf eine weitere folge wenn
ihr auf bock drauf habe dass noch nach
oben da schreitet in die kommentare
das was von mir haut rein und wir sehen
uns schon